(soulful music)
(record scratch)
- Oh, hey, Tracy.
(soulful music)
Things Olivia Pope does that
would be weird if you did them.
- Hey Seth, what's wrong?
- I just spilled water on my
computer, I think it's broken.
- Okay, I need you to listen to me,
listen to me closely and
follow my instructions exactly.
You're gonna take this
computer to the storage closet
and you're gonna leave
it on the third shelf.
Then, you're gonna take
this ticket to Kansas,
go spend some time with your lovely mother
and lay low for a month
until this all blows over.
Do you understand?
- My mom doesn't live in Kansas.
Sustenance.
- Hey guys.
- Thanks for volunteering to
help clean the kitchen guys.
Patrick, can you do the counter tops?
- Tracy, I want you to
empty the dishwasher.
- You don't get to say that!
If you want me, earn me!
- Guys, I've got some sad news,
last night we had to let someone go,
and, well, Bob will not be
working with us anymore.
- No, he can't go, we
were supposed to stand
in the sun together.
- Tracy, tell me about this
new guy you've been dating.
- Oh, my God, he is so funny, he's tall,
he works out all the time,
he's married with three kids...
- Wait, he's married?
- He's also the President
of the United States.
- The fuck?
- And I'm pretty sure he killed my mama.
- What?!
- I love him okay and we
are gonna be together!
- So, the great thing about this is that
we should not be met with
a lot of defiance when it
comes to submitting--
- Defiance? Did you say Defiance?
Who told you about defiance?
- That sweater fits you really well.
- Thank you.
- Fitz? Is Fitz here?
- 7:52, 7:52, 7:52...
- Should we call someone?
- Hey, hey, excuse me,
excuse me, he's with me,
he's with me, no problem, excuse me.
- I think if we keep our
performance up then we're
in for some pretty profitable
gains for next year.
- (slow clapping) Bravo, bravo.
- Jesus, Jesus, Mellie, not now, not now.
(soulful music)
- It's handled.
- Thank you?